Hier, une bonne partieen fourna,
ça se poursuit.
- Avec le réchauffement
climatique et toutes
les modifications qu'il peut
y avoir, bien c'est vrai
- Chaude...
(rires)
...extr
- Anormalement chaude oui,
c'est le mot.
- La France, après avoir brisé
des dizaines de records météo,
voit la canicule se déplacer
ératures qui atteignent
quarante degrés.
Et puis, le terriçais
continue de brûler. Des milliers
d'hectares incendiés dans
la région de Bordeaux, 2000
pompiers en renfort et plus
PATRICK DAVET, maire de la
Teste-de-Buch, Gironde
- Économiquement, ça va être
très difficile pour eux et très
difficile pour la commune.
Je vous laisse imalle
touristique et la saison,
nous en avons besoin.
- Des grands incendies font
également toujours
en Espagne, alimentées
par la vague de chaleur
et la sécheresse.
Au Portu
des personnes âgées, sont causés
par la température écrasante.
Au Royaume-Uni, un pays
sous équipé pour les chaleursmat
dernière et a dépassé le seuil
grés durant le jour.
En fait, selon les experts
du climat, l'Europ
maintenant devenu la région
du monde la plus fréquemment
sujette à des épisodes
En bonne partie en raison
de l'impact des changements
climatiques.actuelle va se déplr
vers l'est de l'Europe durant
les prochains jourle
se poursuivra jusqu'au milieu
mand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Mon